Cheers yeah BAM what are you drinking
free well it left immediately knew what
was gonna happen oh don't even
I'm here with Tyler and bain-marie and
today we're playing shoes that you do
everybody's a hue hue hue hue where I
took photos of youtubers and I cropped
them very closely so you only see a very
specific part of the vine I'm going to
show them that tiny tiny part and then
they're gonna have to ring in and guess
who that usually ring in under each
other in the face well I mean I think
that you need you to create what your
spirit noise is and that's how you ring
in yeah PA system I know
oh yeah I 10 photos of youtubers and
then I have one extra in case there's a
try for some reasons your first photo
[Music]
you don't lose a point but you can only
do that once if you do it Tyler Oakley
no oh
do you see me doing that yeah no no I'll
give you a hint it's a man oh yes yeah I
can tell because he's got that mouth
[Music]
it's like just a little whisper oh
stroke yeah that actually you don't get
points for
that was our warm-up number two did you
even bring your dingdong daily here we
go Ricky Dillon knows Jack Douglas no
but close I can see where you're going
what in tarnation don't bring that no
it's a man no no yeah I'm sure
Troy okay yeah next photo yeah right Joe
Sutter No
Tyler Thunderbird no I will say you're
on the right track
No Mas either ring in no no doubtful
Jacky poon know that you're out winner
takes off yeah
because you know cool stuff happens over
there deuces take it away okay you did